you
hello hello is that Alvin Roth it is
hello my name is Allegra ravilious i'm
calling from nobelprize.org the Nobel
Prize website sorry to bother you so
early in the morning and we're already
up I expect so nobelprize.org have a
tradition of recording short telephone
interviews with new laureates and I was
hoping we could have a quick chat now
okay I'm having a little trouble hearing
you can you speak up oh right yes of
course I'll speak up well first of all
congratulations thank you how do you
feel today well how did you feel when
you when you receive the news well I'm
surprised but it's still too early in
the morning for me to have more
particularly feelings than that I
imagine it's going to be a busy day or
my iphone is already started to ring I
understand many of Nobel Prize dogs
visitors are high school students how
would you explain your prize awarded
work in easy terms in layman's terms
well my prize is about matching matching
is the work that the economy does when
deciding for instance which students
will go to which schools if they if they
have a choice so so high school students
in some cities get matched to to a
choice system where they submit
preferences and the schools have
requirements or perhaps preferences also
and and then some decisions are made
about who goes where and that's what
matching is about it's about who gets
what and we try to in school choice we
try to make that happen in a way that
that's efficient that doesn't send
people to schools that they would rather
swap with with other people and if the
schools would allow them and if your
students are in high school then they're
going to go through many matching
markets in their lives there they're
gonna get married they're gonna get jobs
so they can think about a family so your
work has a lot of practical applications
in our lives school applications may be
matching kidney donors and receivers are
you driven as an economist by these
questions by applying your theories to
real life yeah economics is about real
life so so I'm very interested in that
and when you recruit postdocs and
students
you apply the same theories well my
postdocs are all are all different and
but they're all interested in economics
and how it shapes our lives and how we
can learn more about it you know we we
want to try to make things better but we
also want to learn to understand that
those are those are related tasks
different postdocs you know have
different points of view yeah indeed so
as a young person what inspired you to
become an economist well I didn't become
an economist until till rather late in
life my PhD is in operations research I
was interested in making things work
better and using mathematics to help do
that and so that's what I operations
research is what I studied as an
undergraduate and as a graduate student
but the kinds of things that I found
myself interested in trying to
understand and try to make work better
wear things that involved people and
that led me to economics and today you
teach a course called experimental
economics is that what you're talking
about now is oh can you tell us more
about that well so I teach you two
courses today one is called market
design and one is called experimental
economics it's a Monday and experimental
economics is about conducting
experiments look bringing economics into
the laboratory or creating controlled
conditions in the field that allow us to
understand better what we're seeing in
less controlled circumstances and market
design is about understanding the
details of markets in sufficient detail
so that we can help fix them when they
were broken in 1988 you wrote a book
called the Shapley value essays in honor
of lloyd as sharply Howard did his work
influenced you well so Lloyd Shapley and
David gale developed the first clear
theory of what's called stable matching
and they thought about algorithms say
they really wrote a you know they didn't
think of it that way at the time but
they really wrote a very early market
design paper and I've been a big
follower of theirs in the sense that
that I wrote a book with the Sotomayor
in 1990 that it was called two-sided
matching and it sort of followed up the
developments in the intervening 30 years
in in that in the theory of those
markets so so I'm a you know I a big
follower of voids and it's gonna be a
great honor to get the prize together
with him you
is I read that you have a blog and you
don't want good move on and your latest
post you wrote about the correlation
between a country's chocolate
consumption to the number of nobel
prizes they get what would you pose
today well I don't know I I may not have
time to blog today it's shaping up to be
a busy day as I as I speak to you I'm
hearing beeps that suggests that other
people are calling on the telephone I
understand last question how are you
going to celebrate today if you get
really soon I'm gonna have a cup of
coffee that sounds good that sounds
excellent well congratulations are you
looking forward to meeting you in
stockholm in december i'm looking
forward already ok thank you thank you
bye-bye